dernière ligne droite pour ces cyclistes
venus de toute la France 34 adolescents
âgés de 14 à 18 ans participé à la cyclo
randonnée du Paris-Brest Paris des
jeunes organisé par la Fédération
Française de cycles touristes ce
parcourt relire Rambouillet jusqu'au
Finistère aller-retour 12 étapes pour un
périple débuter le 12 août dernier une
aventure humaine à travers les paysages
de l'Hexagone ça dépasse le vélo on
découvre quand même des des régions on
découvre des gens voilà
ça dépasse les profs physiques et juste
le le chronomètre ils ont tous été
déconnectés c'est ça qui m'a surpris le
plus c'est-à-dire qu'on a même des
endroits où on avait aucune couverture
WiFi ça leur a posé aucun problème ce
jeudi 24 août marqué à la fin de la 9e
édition du Paris-Brest Paris des jeunes
une arrivée mêlée à celle de la cyclo
randonnée des adultes
après 1200 km parcourus et passionné de
la petite reine laissez éclater leur
joie de retour à Rambouillet un
itinéraire conséquent nécessitant
plusieurs mois de préparation physique
et mentale en amont
janvier et donc régulièrement vous êtes
des sorties avec le Club des Jeunes le
samedi puis petit à petit avec les
adultes le dimanche matin et on a
continué à faire du vélo même tout seul
partout quand je suis allé chez mes
grands-parents en voyage prenez mon vélo
et je suis arrivée jusqu'ici ce per et
son fils du Vélo Club de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ont décidé de
pédaler ensemble sur ce parcours c'était
pas si dur que ça je m'attendais à être
plus dur mais
c'était assez chouette c'est très
intéressant
comme expérience et je suis fier de moi
je suis très content parce que
voilà même si je savais qu'il en avait
les capacités après voilà il y a 1200 km
à faire il peut se passer plein de
choses en num mécanique physique parce
que quand même le corps est quand même
pas mal sollicité donc ouais je suis
content qu'il soit arrivé au bout je
suis très fier et puis ça donne c'est un
bon tremplin pour pour la suite un
tremplin laissant espérer une
participation au prochain Paris-Brest
Paris version adulte le rendez-vous est
pris pour dans 4 ans